[Music]
ben is with us ben
is in kentucky hi ben welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hi dave how's it going better than i
deserve what's up
hey uh so my situation is basically
i've got my debt is i've got a mortgage
and i've got an hvac system that i just
put in
the house and um the deal with the hvac
system
is it's a zero percent apr meaning that
i don't pay any interest on it right
now and so i was wondering first off
if you think i should um just go ahead
because i know i've
read a lot of your stuff and you talk
about the snowball effect and paying off
the small stuff first so
i was wondering um even though it's a
zero percent apr
uh if you recommend uh paying that off
first
before uh going more in on the mortgage
because right now i'm just basically
attacking the mortgage and just paying
month to month with the zero percent apr
uh just the minimum that i have to on
the hvac and then
you don't have any other debt correct
no i have the mortgage and just the no
credit cards no car loans anything like
that
well then yeah i would i would yeah stay
current with the mortgage but i wouldn't
pay extra on it and i would get this
thing paid off because even though
the zero interest is there
mathematically i understand your your
thought process
but it's the emotional side of still
owing that right like there's still
money to be owed and so getting that out
of your life completely building up that
emergency fund and then walking through
the baby steps
is what i would do we try to just
rationalize so much of our money
mistakes or decisions based on math and
at the end of the day
it is so much more than math it is so
much more than math and that's what you
have to take into account but
yeah mathematically i understand what
you're saying but there is a there's an
emotional spiritual side to money
that when you don't owe anyone anything
things start to change
yeah yeah you just need to be free when
you play games with
i'm you're not going to get wealthy with
borrowed money on a vacuum
it's just
i got zero percent on my vacuum heating
and air yeah well i mean
or you're heating an air system it's
just you know said no millionaire ever
the zero percent on my hvac caused me to
become wealthy
it just doesn't come up being and
staying debt-free
and not having cash flow and not having
stuff around my neck
when weird crap happens is by far
uh superior to that so yeah write a
check pay that off as soon as you
possibly can
and don't pay extra on your mortgage
until you have that done and have a
fully funded emergency fund
that's simple don't do it